well brian with everything costing more
and a recession on the horizon we can
all use a little extra cash from our
everyday purchases kirsten joyce spoke
to a consumer financial expert about how
to make that happen
inflation is soaring and even after
you've cut out discretionary purchases
you still may not have enough to afford
this higher cost of living have your
spending work in your favor consumer
finance expert andrea warrock says try a
new credit card credit card rewards give
you cash back for different spending
categories but you really have to figure
out where you spend the most money to
make sure you get a card that aligns
with that so look at your year-end
statement from last year did you spend
more on travel dining out groceries you
can look up cash back cards at
cardrates.com
review the different options to find the
best one for your spending style other
cashback tools include couponcabin.com
with thousands of online retailers and
merchants if you're ordering your
groceries online you can get three
percent back at bonds.com up to two
dollars and fifty cents back at
instacart they have cashback for
ubereats grubhub
gap macy's kohl's walmart amazon the
point is most of us do our shopping
online these days and so easy to click
through
couponcabin.com and make some extra cash
check out sites like inbox dollars and
survey junkie they pay you anywhere from
a few bucks up to 50 bucks to take
online surveys you can take a survey
while you're binge watching your
favorite show on netflix or if you're
traveling and waiting to board a flight
pull it up on your phone why not turn
that spare time into some extra spending
cash kirsten joyce live local now
fetch rewards is another cash back tool
every time you're done shopping just
take a photo of your receipt to earn
points and you can put that towards free
gift